[Musique]
tout le monde connaît la décoration sur
les fenêtres avec la bombe et la neige
synthétique sachez que c'est hyper
polluant le contenant est une
catastrophe le gaz à l'intérieur est
catastrophique et la neige est
catastrophique il y a une solution qui
est bien plus simple plus facile
d'utilisation plus facile d'entretien et
moins cher alors faudrait pas c'est un
comble de s'en passer c'est le stylo
craie ce que les commerçants utilisent
pour écrire sur les ardoises ou sur les
fenêtres pour ceux qui ont regardé
Amélie Poulain elle écrit avec ses
stylos là donc maintenant on en trouve
dans les commerces en plus de plusieurs
couleurs il y en a des bleus des dorés
des vers des rouges de toutes les
couleurs donc ce stylo craie il a
l'avantage de s'effacer très facilement
vous prenez simplement sur Internet
coloriage et juste des traits tout
simple vous le scotchez de l'autre côté
de la fenêtre parce que vous vous avez
une fenêtre qui s'ouvre alors c'est
vachement plus pratique
et vous vous en servez comme d'un calque
et là
vous dessinez comme ça ça vous permet
par exemple pour les enfants d'abord
d'apprendre à dessiner et puis de se
tromper et c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave parce qu'en fait le plus important
c'est qu'on s'amuse avec les enfants
donc les enfants ils ont fait un espèce
de bonhomme de neige qui ressemble à ça
et ça vous plaît pas et ben vous prenez
votre chiffon vous avez mis un petit peu
d'eau dessus
et voilà votre vitre elle est propre